there you go
so
um
good evening my fellow americans tonight
i'd like to talk to you about where we
are as we mark
one year since everything stopped
because of this pandemic
a year ago we're hit with a virus
that was met with silence and spread
unchecked
denials for days weeks then months
that led to more deaths more infections
more stress and more loneliness
photos and videos from 2019
feel like they were taken in another era
the last vacation the last birthday with
friends
the last holiday with extended family
while it was different for everyone we
all lost something
a collective suffering a collective
sacrifice
a year filled with the loss of life
and the loss of living for all of us
but in the loss we saw how much there
was to gain
in appreciation respect and gratitude
finding light in the darkness is a very
american thing to do in fact
it may be the most american thing we do
and that's what we've done we've seen
frontline and essential workers risking
their lives sometimes losing
them to save and help others
researchers and scientists racing for a
vaccine
and so many of you as hemingway wrote
being strong in all the broken places
i know it's been hard i truly know
as i've told you before i carry a card
in my pocket
with the number of americans who have
died
from covert to date it's on the back of
my schedule
as of now total deaths in america
527 thousand
seven hundred and twenty six
that's more deaths than in world war one
world war ii the vietnam war
and nine eleven combined they were
husbands
wives sons and daughters grandparents
friends
neighbors young and old
they leave behind loved ones unable to
truly grieve or to heal even to have a
funeral
but i'm also thinking about everyone
else who lost this past year
to natural causes by cruel fate of
accident or other disease
they too died alone they too leave
behind
loved ones who are hurting badly
you know you've often heard me say
before i talk about the longest walk
any parent can make is up a short flight
of stairs to his
child's bedroom to say i'm sorry
i lost my job can't be here anymore
like my dad told me when he lost his job
in scranton
so many of you had to make that same
walk this past year
you lost your job you closed your
business
facing eviction homelessness hunger
a loss of control may be worst of all a
loss of hope
watching a generation of children who
may be set back up to a year or more
because they've not been in school
because of their loss of learning it's
the details of life that matter
most and we miss those details
the big details and the small moments
weddings birthdays graduations
all the things that needed to happen but
didn't
the first date the family reunions
the sunday night rituals it's all
has exacted a terrible cost on the
psyche of so many of us
for we are fundamentally a people who
want to be with others
to talk to laugh to hug
to whole another but this
virus has kept us apart and grandparents
haven't seen their children or
grandchildren parents
haven't seen their kids kids haven't
seen their friends
the things we used to do that always
filled us with joy
had become things we couldn't do and
broke our hearts
too often we've turned against one
another
a mask the easiest thing to do to save
lives
sometimes it divides us states
pitted against one another instead of
working with each other
vicious hate crimes against asian
americans
who've been attacked harassed blamed and
scapegoated
at this very moment so many of them are
fellow americans
they're on the front lines of this
pandemic trying to save lives
and still still they're forced to live
in fear
for their lives just walking down
streets in america
it's wrong it's un-american and it
must stop
look we know what we need to do to beat
this virus
tell the truth follow the scientists
the science work together put trust and
faith in our government to fulfill its
most
important function which is protecting
the american people
no function more important we need to
remember the government isn't some
foreign force in the distant capital no
it's us
all of us we the people
for you and i that america thrives
when we give our hearts when we turn our
hands
to common purpose and right now my
friends
we're doing just that and i have to say
as your president i'm grateful to you
last summer i was in philadelphia
and i met a small business owner a woman
i asked her i said what do you need most
never forget what she said to me she
said looking behind the eyes she said
i just want the truth the truth
just tell me the truth
think of that my fellow americans
you wrote nothing less than the truth
and for all of you asking when things
will get back to normal
here is the truth the only way to get
our lives back
to get our economy back on track is to
beat
the virus you've been hearing me say
that for while i was running and the
last
50 days i've been president but this is
one of the most
complex operations we've under ever
undertaken as a nation in a long time
that's why i'm using every power i have
as president of the united states
to put us on a war footing to get the
job done
sounds like hyperbole but i mean it a
war footing
and thank god we're making some real
progress now
and my first full day in office i
outlined for you a comprehensive
strategy to beat this pandemic
we've spent every day since attempting
to carry it out
two months ago the country this country
didn't have nearly enough vaccine
supply to vaccinate all or ever near all
of the american
public but soon we will
we've been working with vaccine
manufacturers pfizer moderna johnson and
johnson
to manufacture and purchase hundreds of
millions of doses
of these three safe effective vaccines
and now at the direction and with the
assistance of my administration
johnson johnson is working together with
a competitor
merck to speed up and increase the
capacity
to manufacture new johnson and johnson
vaccine which was one shot
in fact just yesterday i announced
and i met with the ceos of both
companies i announced
our plan to buy an additional 100
million doses
of johnson and johnson vaccines
these two companies competitors have
come together for the good of the nation
and they should be applauded for it
it's truly a national effort just like
we saw during world war
ii now because all the work we've done
we'll have enough vaccine supply for all
adults in america by the end of may
that's months ahead of schedule and
we're mobilizing
thousands of vaccinators to put the
vaccine in one's arm
calling active duty military fema
retired doctors and nurses
administrators
and those to administer the shots
and we've been creating more places to
get the shots
we've made it possible for you to get a
vaccine at nearly
one any one of 10 000 pharmacies across
the country
just like you get your flu shot we're
also working with governors and mayors
in red states and blue states to set up
and support nearly 600
federally supported vaccination centers
that administers
hundreds of thousands of shots per day
you can drive up to a stadium or a large
parking lot
get your shot never leave your car and
drive home
in less than an hour
we've been sending vaccines to hundreds
of community health centers
all across america located in
underserved areas
and we've been deploying and we will
deploy more mobile vehicles and pop-up
clinics
to meet you where you live so those who
are least able to get the vaccine are
able to get it
we continue to work on making at home
testing available
and we've been focused on serving people
in the hardest hit communities of this
pandemic
black latino native american and rural
communities
so what does all this add up to when i
took office 50 days ago
only eight percent of the americans
after months
only eight percent of those over the age
of 65 have gotten their first
vaccination
today that number is 65 percent
just 14 of americans
over the age of 75 50 50 days ago had
gotten their first shot
today that number is well over 70
percent
with new guidance from the centers for
disease control and prevention
the cdc that came out on monday
it means simply this millions and
millions of grandparents
who went months without being able to
hug their grandkids
can now do so and the more people are
fully vaccinated
the cd will continue to provide
additional guidance
on what you can do in the workplace
places of worship with your friends
as well as travel
when i came into office you may recall i
set a goal that many of you said was a
kind of
way over the top i said i
intended to get a hundred million shots
in people's arms and my first hundred
days in office
tonight i can say we're not only gonna
meet that goal
we're gonna beat that goal because we're
actually on track to reach this goal of
a hundred million shots and arms on my
60th day in office
no other country in the world has done
this
none now i want to talk about the next
steps we're thinking about
first tonight i'm announcing that i will
direct
all states tribes and territories to
make
all adults people 18 and over
eligible to be vaccinated no later than
may 1.
let me say that again all adult
americans will be eligible to get a
vaccine
no later than may 1.
that's much earlier than expected let me
be clear
that doesn't mean everyone's going to
have that shot immediately but it means
you'll be able to get in line beginning
may 1
every adult will eligible get their shot
to do this
we're going to go from a million shots a
day that i promised in december
before ice was sworn in to maintaining
beating our current pace of 2 million
shots a day
outpacing the rest of the world secondly
at the time when every adult is eligible
in may
we will launch with our partners new
tools to make it easier for you to find
the vaccine
and where to get the shot including a
new website that will help you
first find the place to get vaccinated
and the one
nearest you no more searching day and
night
for an appointment for you and your
loved ones
thirdly with the passage of the american
rescue plan
and i thank again the house and senate
for passing it
and my announcement last month of a plan
to vaccinate teachers and school staff
including bus drivers we can accelerate
massive nationwide effort to reopen our
schools
safely and meet my goal that i stated at
the same time about 100 million shots
of opening majority of k-8 schools
in my first hundred days in office this
is going to be the number one priority
of my new secretary of education
miguel cardona fourth
in the coming weeks we will issue
further guidance
on what you can and cannot do once fully
vaccinated
to lessen the confusion to keep people
safe
and encourage more people to get
vaccinated
and finally fifth and maybe most
importantly
i promise i will do everything in my
power
i will not relent until we beat this
virus
but i need you the american people i
need you
i need every american to do their part
that's not hyperbole i need you i need
you to get vaccinated when it's your
turn and when you can find an
opportunity
and to help your family your friends
your neighbors
get vaccinated as well because here's
the point
if we do all this if we do our part
if we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together after this long hard year
that will make this independence day
something truly special
where we not only mark our independence
as a nation
but we begin to mark our independence
from this virus
but to get there we can't let our guard
down
this fight is far from order from over
as i told the woman in pennsylvania
i'll tell you the truth a july
4th with your loved ones is the goal
but a goal a lot can happen
conditions can change the scientists
have made clear
that things may get worse again as new
variants of the virus
spread we've got work to do to ensure
that
everyone has confidence in the safety
and effectiveness of all three vaccines
so our message to you is this listen to
dr fauci
one most distinguished and trusted
voices in the world
he's assured us the vaccines are safe
they underwent rigorous scientific
review
i know they're safe vice president haron
harris and i know they're safe that's
why we got the vaccine
publicly in front of cameras so for the
world to see
so you could see us do it
the first lady the second gentleman also
got vaccinated
talk to your family friends your
neighbors the people you know best
who've gotten the vaccine
we need everyone to get vaccinated
we need everyone to keep washing their
hands
stay socially distanced and keep wearing
the mask
as recommended by the cdc
because even if we devote every resource
we have
beating this virus and getting back to
normal depends on
national unity and national unity isn't
just how politics
and politicians vote in washington what
the loudest voices say in cable or
online
unity is what we do together as fellow
americans because if we don't stay
vigilant
and the conditions change then we may
have to reinstate restrictions
to get back on track and please we don't
want to do that again
we've made so much progress this is not
the time to let up
just as we were emerging from a dark
winter
into a hopeful spring and summer is not
the time
to not stick with the rules
i'll close with this we've lost so much
over the last year
we've lost family and friends we've lost
businesses and dreams we spent years
building
we've lost time time with each other
and our children have lost so much time
with their friends
time with their schools no graduation
ceremonies just
this spring no graduations from college
high school
moving up ceremonies you know there's
something else we lost
we lost faith in whether our government
and our democracy can deliver on really
hard things
for the american people but as i stand
here tonight
we're proving once again something i've
said time and time again to
probably tired of hearing me say it i
say it to foreign leaders and domestic
alike
it's never ever a good bet to bet
against the american people
america is coming back
the development manufacturing
distribution of vaccines and record time
is a true miracle of science
it's one of the most extraordinary
achievements any country has ever
accomplished
we also just saw the perseverance rover
land on mars
stunning images of our dreams that are
now
reality another example of the
extraordinary american ingenuity
commitment and belief in science
and one another and today
i signed in the law the american rescue
plan
an historic piece of legislation to
deliver his immediate relief to millions
of people
includes one thousand four hundred
dollars in direct rescue checks
payments that means a typical family of
four earning about a hundred and ten
thousand dollars will get
checks for five thousand six hundred
dollars deposited if they have direct
deposit
or in a check a treasury check
it extends unemployment benefits it
helps small businesses it lowers
healthcare premiums for many
it provides food and nutrition keeps
families in their homes
and will cut child poverty in this
country in half
according to the experts and a fi
and it funds all the steps i've just
described
to beat the virus and create millions of
jobs
in the coming weeks and months i'll be
traveling along with the first lady the
vice president the second gentleman
members of my cabinet
to speak directly to you to tell you the
truth
about how the american rescue plan meets
the moment
and if it fails at any page i will
acknowledge that it failed
but it will not about how after
long dark years one whole year
there is hope and light of better days
ahead
if we all do our part this country will
be vaccinated soon
our economy will be on the mend our kids
will be back in school
we'll have proven once again
that this country can do anything hard
things
big things important things
over a year ago no one could have
imagined
what we were about to go through but now
we're coming through it and it's a
shared experience
that binds us together as a nation
are bound together by the loss and the
pain and the days
that have gone by we're also bound
together by the hope
and the possibilities of the days in
front of us
my fervent prayer for our country is
that after
all we've been through we'll come
together
as one people one nation
one america i believe we can
and we will we're seizing this moment
in history i believe will record we
faced and overcame one of the toughest
and darkest periods in this nation's
history
darkest we've ever known i promise you
we'll come out stronger with a renewed
faith in ourselves
a renewed commitment to one another to
our communities into our country
this is the united states of america
and there's nothing nothing from the
bottom of my heart i believe this
there's nothing
we can't do when we do it together
so god bless you all
and please god give solace to all those
people who lost someone
and may god protect our troops thank you
for taking the time to listen
i look forward to seeing you
you